أريد أن أسألك عن مقالتك الافتتاحية التي أجريتها
هذا الأسبوع في منشور واشنطن ،
فأنت تقول إن
أفضل سيناريو سنحوله إلى
مرض مثل الأنفلونزا الموسمية ،
وهذا هو أفضل
سيناريو في هذه المرحلة ، يبدو الأمر
أكثر فأكثر مثلنا.  لن نكون
قادرين على القضاء على
الكوفا 19. سيكون معنا ولكن
هذا هو الشيء لأن لدينا هذه
اللقاحات الفعالة للغاية وعلى
وجه الخصوص هناك نقطة نهاية واحدة
لتجارب اللقاح التي يجب أن
نركز عليها حقًا
وهو اللقاح  يخفض معدل
الاستشفاء فعليًا ،
لم يكن هناك أي شخص في
المجموعة التي تلقت اللقاحات أو واحد
أو اثنين من الأشخاص الذين انتهى بهم الأمر إلى
الإصابة بمرض
شديد لدرجة أنهم بحاجة إلى
دخول المستشفى وهذا أمر مهم حقًا
لأنه إذا أصيب الناس
اللقاح ونحن قادرون على تحويل الخوف من
فيروس كورونا من مرض مميت
إلى شيء يسبب لك الحمى
وآلام الجسم ، يمكننا بعد ذلك إعادة فتح المدارس ،
ثم يمكننا إعادة اقتصادنا مرة أخرى
يمكن بعد ذلك أن يكون ople مع عائلاتهم
مرة أخرى
، وبالتالي قد يكون شيئًا
ينتهي بنا الأمر إلى العيش معه ونريد
منعه من أننا ما زلنا نجري اختبارات
لذلك ربما نحصل على
لقطات سنوية منتظمة ولكن يمكننا
وضع حد لهذا الوباء  من خلال
تحويل cobit إلى شيء ما
بين نزلات البرد
والأنفلونزا الموسمية ، لذلك تعتقد أننا
قد نحتاج إلى لقطة تغطية جديدة كل
عام
مع التباين وحقيقة أن
فيروس rna هذا يتحول بسرعة كبيرة
ويبدو من المحتمل أننا ``  سنحتاج إلى
لقطات معززة الآن ، كم مرة
ستستغرق هذه
المدة على الفور ما زلنا
لا نعرف ، لكنني أعتقد
أنه يبدو أكثر فأكثر أننا سنحتاج إلى
لقطات منتظمة من نوع ما
نسمعه من بعض الأشخاص الذين
تلقيت اللقاح بأن التفاعلات
أو الآثار الجانبية
للجرعة الثانية تبدو أقوى من
الأولى ، هل يمكنك توضيح سبب ذلك ،
لذا فإن لقاحات شركة فايزر الحديثة يتم
تصنيعها كلقاح من جرعتين ، لذا أولاً
تحصل على اللقطة المعززة ،
حيث تحصل أولاً على اللقاح التمهيدي
ثم تحصل على المعزز وهكذا يقوم
التمهيدي
بإعداد جسمك ، ثم في المرة الثانية
التي تبدأ فيها الأجسام المضادة بالفعل
في التطور وهكذا عندما
تتعرض لهذا مرة أخرى
جسمك  يتفاعل الآن معها
وأريد أن يعرف الناس أن هذا أمر طبيعي
ومتوقع وجيد ، لذلك عندما
تصاب بهذا الذراع المؤلم عندما تصاب بالحمى بالتعب
مع اللقطة الأولى أو بشكل خاص مع
اللقطة الثانية ، اعلم أن هذا يظهر أن جسمك
هو جهاز المناعة  يبدأ الأمر في
التسارع كما ينبغي
، وفي المرة القادمة إذا تعرضت
لفيروس كورونا ، سيعرف جسمك كيفية
محاربة الغطاء 19.